Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Ben and Ed
I feel In better fashion than I did before
That doesn't mean that I'm anymore fashionable, that just means I feel better
What are you going to do - slice and fall is the name of the game?
Fun. Why did you start it off by calling it slice - oh that's why.
Okay
Well, tits. (.)(.)
Ahh, yes! I made it! In one piece! Shockingly.
Where am I supposed to fall next?
Oh this is stupid. Oh this is thi-stu- stupid!
Oh what the heck
All right, here we go! here we go baby!
Land on it
Yes!
I did it? I think and I got a golden idol of Mumbaba
I love when I get the golden idol of Mumbaba
because that means I'm actually good at what I do.
Not! REALLY!
Oh I'm not going to make this one.
Ooo, man
I think I was close, but I'm not exactly sure
what happened to me. I kinda disappeared
into a pit of despair. Oh frack.
Frack my luck! Okay.
OH! That's a pit of spikes.
What an apt name for the pit of despair in my opinion.
Ow? I probably broke all my bones in my body
Not that it matters because I am the undeadness.
Uh! Oh! Oh okay.
I thought... I thought you were going to be
a douche to me! Alright.
We're just going to do this... methodically!
Oh. Okay then. Never mind. We're fine.
Hyup! ... Okay!
Alright. Everything's okay.
Do I really want those? Yeah, because I need them
to unlock levels, methinks. Whoop!
Eh. Little victory twerk here.
Oh. That's not a twerk.What is that?
Ohhhhhhh kaaaaaaay
I didn't even know those were options
I thought I just- NO!
OH!!! WHY?!?
NO. WHY?
NOOOOO
WHY DID I PUSH THAT BUTTON?
Oh, what heartbreak!
Oh, what horrendous heartbreak!
Why did I bounce and extra time there?
I don't know! I don't know!
Ahhwahh! Oh fuck.
Why can't I get on here now?
What am I doing wrong now?
What's going on now? Huh? Dick. 8===>
There we go. Oh, I made a crack right in the wall there.
Probably. I'm going to take the blame for that one.
Ow?!? Landed right on my neck.
Right on the cushy, soft part of my neck!
OH GOD DAMN IT!
What have I done now?
Can you not twerk for one damn second?
It's like you're obsessed with it!
It's a problem now! It's not even in fashion anymore.
Stop...Ju- Just stop. Dude!
I think some progress is being made here.
I think... I think... Maybe? Maybe? Maybe?
There we go! I made it!
SHIT. Fuck! Alright. There we go.
Well, that was fun. Glad that was a nice little detour
to everything we were supposed to be doing. Ow.
Again, how do I keep doing this?
Horray! We finally frickin' made it.
It's about frickin' time we frickin' did it.
Frick! Frick! Frick! Yes!
[imitating button moan] Hurrr I'm so sad you succeeded
Oh, there wouldn't be a TV sh-
Awwww... no
Noooo, no, no, YOU will die!
Okay, here we go. Alright, let's do this.
It's the stupidest jumps that get me.
It's- it's not anything complicated in the game.
I can dodge anything it throws at me.
Hey! Don't bring up evidence of me not dodging everything it throws at me
because I can do that!
Fuck you! NOOO! AH!
Aw, shit
FUUUUUU-!!!
It's the simple gaps and jumps that I don't see that are the problem.
Like that one there! That was almost a problem
Where are we going now?
What hell hole are you delivering- Oh god. I can see it.
I can see the hole of hell.
Oh, I can see it all. Oh NOOO!
NO! NO!
OH, YOU BITCH! OH, YOU BITCH!
OH! YOU
BITCH!
That was the biggest dick move of any dick move
I've ever seen in my life.
[scathing sarcasm] Ohhh, goodbye. No, I'll wait.
[still sarcastic] Oh, don't worry about me!
[sarcasm continues] I'll be right here!
[sarcastic] Enjoying the environment! I have my water
MMMMM!
I love it when it splashes me back in the face 'cuz I'm in a hurry
Dude, such dick move. God dingus dang it.
What a douche! What a DOUCHE!
Everyone comment about how douchey that move was.
My goodn- Okay I'm over it now.
Wha...!?
What.
What. Why is this...? Ohhh
I was confused. I was very confused.
Okay, that makes more sense
Okay! Got it! Uh oh.
Got it! Okay, where am I going with this one?
Uh oh
Okay, alright, I'm okay. I'm okay.
Alright, where am I going with this one?
Oh kay... this seems like bad.
Ow. Get up get up get up giddup giddup!
Oh, where was it? Oh, okay. I thought it was
passing by directly over
Woo! Oh, that's not a good time.
Whoop! Oh and hup!
Whoa, can't believe I got that.
'Kay, hyoop!
Here we go! SHIT
Oh, god damn it. Get back on the body! On the body!
ON THE BODY! OHHH
[Frustrated Marki groan]
Maybe I can just jump all the way through.
I think I can do that.
I think I can navigate it. Nope. Can't navigate it.
Nope, nope. Can't do that.
I can do this. I can do this.
I believe in myself!
And that's all that matters! Oh, going fast!
♩Oh, almost made it, though!
Almost made it. Almost made it.
No control if I hit something.
Woo. Woo. Woo. Woo! AHHHH!
OHHH! OH!
Yes! Yes! YES! I totally cheated the system and I love it!
Oh, eat it, developers. Eat it aaaaaall.
Uh oh. Wha!
Okay, when are you going to come back?
Wuh-yup
Why do I gotta do this in sequence with everything else
I've already done? Huh? That seems rather douchey
Hah-dehth! You're not going to get me.
I'm too quick for you. Me sly like fox.
Uh oh. Me boned! Oh SHIIIITT!
YES! I'm still alive! I don't even need to reassemble!
Holy titties!
This... by the way, this level... WOOF.
This level is... HYUUH. This level is no joke!
This level is everything that my nightmares are made of.
Okay. I should have known by the name of the level
that it was going to be something terrible.
Eyhh don't fuck up here
[Whimpering]
Yay! Yay!
Yayyy!
Oh, my god.
I don't wanna do another one! I don't wanna do another one!
I don't wanna do another one
That one was hard enough as it was.
But I did it, and that's all that matters, so I'll do another one.
"Ed Fillet" I don't like the sound of that.
How many... How many uh... How many of these have I missed?
I've missed a lot in these stages.
I'll do the bonus ones so I can get some cans of meat
and then in the off camera, I'll go back through 'em
for some weird reason.
I'll do it later
Okay, "Box Fun"
I'm going to be have FUN in this level!
Did you guys hear? It's going to be "FUN!"
Actually, it doesn't seem so bad right off the bat.
Seems pretty cool.
Okay, I can dig it. I'm down with it.
This seems cool.
[button moans]
[mocking the button] Oh no, he's having fun
Oh god! What is that in the distance? Holy shit!
Weee... Weee! (girly Mark is girly)
Oh god, what are those things?
Horrifying moons? Like, who is the set developer on this show?
Ah ha! Some of them, you can push over.
Uh oh. Some of them fall away and kill you.
You know. Okay, so I gotta find... What? Where am I?
Oh. Thank you. Ah! Okay.
I'm down. Seriously, who did they hire to build this pla-
Ayyy Fuck!
OHHH NOOO
All the way back at the beginning?! Are you kidding me?!
Oh god. Do I have to go through the whole god damn game like this?
Is there not going to be another check point anywhere in this bitch?
Oh, I gotta do it every time, too? Oh nooo
OoooHHh nooOOO
I'm boned.
[deep breath]
That didn't sound good.
Didn't you guys hear? This box-
FUCK!
OHHHH It's so
FUN
I'm doing this for meat.
I'm doing it for meat!
I need the meat for some reason, even though
they sound empty and I'm probably not actually getting
anything out of them, but hey,
at least there's a check-a-point. I like a check-a-point.
Meat! Tasty ca- Oh that's candy meat! OH!
Uh oh oh oh OH oh oh no NO! NO! No!
Oh, oh, oh, oh I thought- OH GOD
OH GOD OH GOD
Thank you. I appreciate that.
You gave me an opportunity to fall and I took it.
I- you didn't give me that one, I just took it anyway.
I'm getting a little greedy on my own -heh- destruction.
Oh god. I don't like the look of that one.
Hello buddy! Hello...
'Kay, so this one already is going to fall
Huuuaaah. Oh, I shouldn't have pressed that.
Aw, I needed to go to the other side of that!
That's the opposite of what I needed!
Ohh NOOO
Oh, it was just a button... I thought I should press it.
Made it! I'm the best! I'M THE BEST! Look at me!
I'm the greatest. Okay, even though I shouldn't have done that
I'm going to claim that it was supposed to be done
and it was an effort to show my skill!
Oh, this is so fun.
Frick you!
Frick you, frick you! Oh frick you, baby!
Frick yeah! Uh oh
Uhhh... Checkpoint? I like the sound of that.
Can I? Please? Thank you, and yes!
And off we go! Okay. So far so good.
Horrible moons aside, everything is going hunky dory for me
and I'm loving life! Even though I'm dead.
I need to reiterate that. I'm very dead.
Everything I do is about me being dead.
Oh, thank you. I needed that. Alright.
Up? What's that mean?
Oh, there's a checkpoint over there.
Hoop! Thank you! That was very important, actually.
If I hadn't gotten that I woulda been boned forever
and ever and ever and ever and ever and ever
Even though I reiterated many times throughout this episode
I am boned. Forever.
Hyecgh
Okay. Ah ha! You can't hide from me!
Gimme your meat! Yes! Delicious meat.
Okay, where does that go?
Okay, so far so good.
That... I can't get up there.
But I can go around...
I don't know what I was jumping on, but it was something.
Gonna make it, gonna make it, gonna make it. Op!
Alright.
♩I don't know where this is going, I don't know where this is going!
But I hope it's gonna be good.
There better be some bonus meat over there.
Shit! Oh god.
Like seriously. I don't wanna be that guy
and criticize video game logic here,
but I'm going to be that guy and I'm going to criticize video game logic here.
How in the hell- shit
How in the hell...
Am I supposed to
Do I aim for YOU?
Ka... Boom!
Kaboom! I missed! Goodbye, Sir.
How 'bout another one?
I'm gonna give ya another face full of this ya nightmare monstrosity.
Take it from a higher angle, baby! OOOHHH
Shit.
I'm gonna get ya! I'm gonna get you eventually.
You're going to see what's going to happen when I go down your gullet!
That sounded oddly sexual, but it's NOT!
It was anything BUT sexual!
Heh. Aw, right in your mouth! Bitch!
I didn't get anything for that, but it makes me feel good!
I don't know why I'm doing it either.
I think I'm losing my god damn mind.
You? You want some? You want some of this too?
BANG! I missed!
BANG! Is that gonna getch'ya?
Weee! Aw, missed.
How 'bout you? You wanna face full of this? BANG!
Ow, my neck is bwoke (broke)
Alright, I guess we're just going over here.
Bang!
Okay, what was the point of that?
I have a feeling I was supposed to do something else about that
because that because that seemed like a counter intuitive
way to go about doing nothing, and I missed some cans.
Why did I go there? Oh maybe to bypass all the shit
Maybe that's all it was. It was just a shortcut.
Make my life a little bit easier.
Which I do appreciate! I really do!
Ah, thank you!
Only a few more left I must be- Yeah I think that's the goal over there
Ahw, tits.
Hello? Hi secret! Ah ha! Oh oh, oh no
That was not a good idea
Okay, so I gotta be a little bit quicker about that
but there is something over there. Something secret.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Whoa.
Whoa! Whoa! AUGH god damn it
Whoa. Fuck, oh come on!
Man, because some of it, is like, it's like sticky
directional, like, the way you jump is often just the way you face
and you'll jump forward that way as opposed to
going the way you want to go
so if you're facing the wrong direction when you make the jump,
... it tosses you in a different way.
I've now eaten up about fifteen minutes trying this bullshit.
and I'm not going to stop until I get it, but I just
wanted to comment about how much time I'm wasting.
What else am I going to be doing with my time?
Eating
(distorted) dicks.
Fuck, jump when you j- auuhhh
Oh, come on. That's auughhh
Oh, why would you jump that way?!
Whyhyhy?!
Why? I was pointed the other way!
Why would you randomly choose to jump off into the abyss?
[montage music]
[montage music]  Oh, fuck
[montage music] Fuck
[montage music]
[montage music]  Oh fuck
[montage music] Oh fuck! Fuck!
[montage music] Oh, god damn it.
[montage music] Oh, come ON!
[montage music. Mark's voice now has an echo] I've been playing this particular area for 30 minutes now
[montage music]
[montage music ends]
Oh, WHYYY
WHY DO YOU GO IN THE FUCKING WRONG DIRECTION?
[Marki sighs. I think he needs a kitten break.]
[fart sound]
[Marki is quiet and intense]
[very loud] NOOOO! OH GOD
THAT WAS IT!
[you're blowing out the mic, Mark, calm down]
[screaming]
N-no. WHAT THE FUCK NO GOD DAMN IT FUCK
Ohhhh I hit the wrong button
FUCK!
Auuuhhh! FUUUUUUck
Auuuhhh! FUUUUUUCCKKKK
[through gritted teeth] Augh
COME ON!
Please, I'm begging you. Just cooperate with me.
It's ugghhh
Fuck! I can't do it! I can't fucking do it, okay?!
Fucking criminy! Jesus Christ!
Oh, Fuck! I've been doing this for two and a half hours!
[frustrated screaming]
I bet I'm really good at it now
I bet I'm really really unbelievably good at this game
which is really really weird and I'm gonna see how that plays out
by me trying to get through this area
Well, look at this. It's a bunch of bullshit.
I still fail at it. My god.
I cannot explain to you how aggravating,
aggravating beyond aggravating that is
that was... that whole section is just set up for failure
because... I'll- I'll explain why
If it wasn't clear in my inane ramblings and
assorted screamings, why that was...
Oh no. [laughs] God damn it.
Why it was awful, and I'll do it as soon as I get past
this fucking part, 'cuz I can do this bullshit.
What? What? [laughs]
God damn it, of course
My fingers are so set up for that one run
that I can't do simple shit now!
Oh, man.
*Markimoo intense time*
Why are you flinging me forward?
Oh my god, you gotta be joking me.
Oh man
*time to calm down*
Okay. Wow. I cannot explain to you guys how aggravating that was
Words cannot describe the kind of literal, physical pain
that I went through to try to accomplish that.
It was unreal how sporadic and different it was
every time, the combination of the lighting, the physics of it,
and timing the jumps, it was so different every time!
I was so good at it, yet I was so bad!
And I was so close so many times!
I was right there! And arguably, on that one attempt
when I hit the wrong button because my body is, like,
trained... I go trained to the point where if I thought I was going to fail,
I just hit it anyway instictively, and I think I could have made it!
Because of the weird way the physics is set up!
Ohhh my gooodddd
It was so painful, I can't describe the pain
and the reward? You want to know what the reward was for all of that bullshit?
It's some creepy-pasta Ben drowned bullshit.
It's aggravating how up their own ass the developer is
to think that I would care!
That I would even remotely care about your MS Paint
bullshit drawing! "Oh my god, it's so creepy!"
That's so stupid! It's so stupid!
I'm sorry! It's stupid!
For the pain you made me go through?!
And I didn't even get to the end of it!
I was there like five times and I couldn't finish!
[frustrated noise]
I have never been through so much pain playing a game,
even playing the 20 20 20 modes for FNaF
was not as aggravating as that
and I literally couldn't do it. I physically couldn't do it.
I physically could not do it because
FNaF 20 mode might have been random,
this was random to the most infuriating degree in that
your controls were not precise.
So fuck that!
I'm going to go on with my life, and enjoy sunshine and rainbows!
And something to give me joy because I have no joy left
in my soul! I have nothing! I have NOTHING!
NOTHING! NU-
[outro music starts] So thank you everybody so much for watching
I appreciate you guys sticking with me
And thanks again for watching
And as always, I will see you in the next video
Bubye!
I am dead inside.
♩Crazy la Paint